So, how does our relationship with technology affect our relationship with other people?
Last year, a study found that excessive Facebook use is damaging towards relationships,...
...where higher use is correlated with a higher frequency of feelings of jealousy...
...and Facebook-related conflict.
Our use of technology and devices is on the rise...
...and it does change the way couples of all ages communicate, show affection...
...and share special moments.
Is it for better or worse?
And it means different things to different people.
How you use your smartphone depends on your attachment style in relationships.
One study found that a greater use of social network apps...
...was positively associated with intimacy and support...
...for people with higher attachment anxiety.
So, it seems like there's a feedback loop.
People with more attachment anxiety in relationships alleviate this...
...by using their phone to seek more contact and intimacy from their partner,...
...which leads to more of an attachment to their partner...
...and maybe even to their phones themselves.